assa larbi sauna en beaujolais près de
lyon l'ancien journaliste devenu maire
stéphane parisot ne veut pas avoir à
choisir dans son exécutif municipal les
tendances vont de zemmoura mélenchon en
passant par macron une commune sans
étiquette ou plutôt toutes étiquettes
confondues et une volonté de ne pas
politiser la vie municipale puis nous
sommes là pour travailler pour l'intérêt
général pour les citoyens sans étiquette
politique donc prendre une position en
parrainant tel ou tel candidat
c'est prendre le risque de perdre la
paix à politique du conseil municipal
stéphane parisot est loin d'être le seul
dans cette position début février on ne
comptait que 40 parrainage dans le rhône
et la métropole de lyon dont celui de
seulement sept mers une situation qui
s'explique selon lui également par le
manque de confidentialité de ses
parrainages
parrainer ce n'est pas soutenir mais
pour la majorité des gens les deux sont
associés si vous prenez une position en
faveur de tel ou tel candidat pour les
électeurs ou pour vos concitoyens
c'est comme si vous le soutenir pour
autant l'envi de défendre la démocratie
fera très probablement changer d'avis le
maire de salars bisso na parrainer des
candidats bien placé dans les sondages
mais qui peine à recueillir leurs 500
parrainages est une option qu'il ne veut
pas laisser de côté je n'accorderai pas
mon parrainage à un candidat qui est
créditée de 1% des intentions de vote ça
n'a aucun sens par contre un candidat
qui a une chance de se retrouver au 2e
tour
si ce candidat ne peut pas se présenter
nous avons un grave problème de
fonctionnement de la démocratie les
parrainages de dernière minute pourrait
accélérer la fin de campagne de certains
candidats ils ont jusqu'au 4 mars à 18
heures pour recueillir leurs 500
signatures